The Daily Beast tracks down the
nefarious American who made a funny
video about Nancy Pelosi Democrats turn
on Joe Biden in Nancy Pelosi struggles
with impeachment I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show the media really
doing yeoman's work over the weekend I
mean really hard work that nobody wants
to do well get to that in just one
second first no one really has time to
go to the post office you're busy who's
got time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it's
a real hassle which is why you need
stamps calm it's one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
Sam Strom eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you time and money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office direct
to your computer which is amazing
whether you're a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages today
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in the mailbox it is that
simple with stamps calm you got 5 cents
off every first class stamp up to 40%
off Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com it's a
no-brainer saving you time and money
no wonder over 700,000 small businesses
including the Daily wire already use
stamps calm right now my listeners get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamps comm enter Shapiro ok so
over the weekend the media proved that
they really stand up for the American
people how by tracking down a Rando who
made a video about Nancy Pelosi now I've
never been a fan of the phrase enemy of
the people that President Trump uses
about the press I think it is
overwrought I think that it is a phrase
that has Stalinist origins Stalin
himself used to use the phrase in order
to make excuses for shooting people so I
don't really believe in use of the
phrase the enemy of the people to
describe the media but if the media want
to make themselves wildly unpopular if
the media seek to spread the perception
that Trump is right about them all they
have to do is keep doing this kind of
stuff so over the weekend the The Daily
Beast ran a piece by one Kevin Poulsen
who himself by the way is a convicted
felon I believe who
wrote a piece called we found the guy
behind the viral drunk Pelosi video now
this video you remember a couple of
weeks ago it came out on the internet
and it was just the apotheosis of evil
in today's modern American politics what
was it it was Nancy Pelosi slowed down a
little bit to look like she was drunk
now as somebody whose words are
routinely slowed down so that it sounds
like I am drunk in joke videos all I
could do was kind of laugh this is just
the way people act online welcome to the
world of online politics where people
make funny stupid little videos and then
post them but this was meritorious of a
full-scale investigation by The Daily
Beast and it really is reminiscent of
the time that Joe Wurzelbacher the the
plumber who was who was on his driveway
when Barack Obama came to visit in 2008
his neighborhood and then he asked
Barack Obama about the debt and he asked
him about spending and then the media
proceeded to uncover every single detail
about Joe the Plumber well this is sort
of the same thing except that at least
Joe the plumbers face was on video in
this particular case the guy who made
the video was just some guy so what did
the media do The Daily Beast went ahead
and discovered everything about him and
then published it online now it would be
one thing if this guy had turned out to
be some sort of Republican political
operative if they'd investigated and it
turned out that he was an intern at
senator Mitch McConnell's office or
something but it is not a story that a
random person posted a random video that
will then went viral the person's
identity is really not supremely
important it truly is not and yet the
Daily Beast not only went out there and
discovered things about him and then
publicized it which means that this guy
is now gonna have a tough time getting a
job simply for making a funny video
about Nancy Pelosi he's now going to be
excoriated by the left-wing media he's
now going to be made persona non grata
in his industry whatever that is
here is the daily beast story on May
22nd Donald Trump super fan an
occasional sports blogger from the Bronx
named Shaun Brooks posted a video clip
of Nancy Pelosi on his personal Facebook
page the clip showed Pelosi and her most
excitable
stammering during a press conference as
she voiced frustration over an aboard of
infrastructure meeting with the
president Brooks's commentary on the
video was succinct is Pelosi drunk
thirteen minutes later a Facebook
official told The Daily Beast
Brooks posted a very different Pelosi
video to a Facebook page called politics
watchdog one of a series of hyper par
News Operations Brooks runs with help he
claims this clip had been altered to
slow Pelosi down without lowering the
pitch of her voice the effect was to
make it sound as though the Speaker of
the House was slurring her words
drunkenly while criticizing Donald Trump
15 minutes after that the same doctored
video appeared on a second Facebook page
Brooks manages all news 24/7 this clip
was identical to the politics watchdog
video in every way except it didn't
carry the politics watchdog branding
that was superimposed over the earlier
video whoever posted it had access to
the director's cut on both pages the
clip was accompanied by the exact same
dispassionate newsy prose House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi on president Trump walking
out infrastructure meeting it was very
very very strange the video was an
instant social media smash surging
through the Internet's well-worn ley
lines of credulity and venom it was
shared more than 60,000 times on
Facebook and accumulated 4 million page
views from links drunk as a skunk mused
actor turned all trite curmudgeon James
woods whose tweet of the video scored 17
thousand retweets and 55,000 likes what
is wrong with Nancy Pelosi wrote Rudy
Giuliani
her speech pattern is bizarre so what do
they do they wouldn't uncovered the guy
and then they proceeded to try to shame
him online for posting a video in which
he slowed down her speech slightly again
you know how easy it is to do that and
people who listen my podcast many of
them listen to my podcast on twice speed
or 1.5 speed many of them probably
listen to it at 0.75 speed if you listen
to my podcast at 0.5 speed you will get
the exact same tenor of my voice except
I will now sound like I am slurring my
words and I am deeply drunk is that an
act of tremendous malicious evil it does
that merit everybody who posts video of
me talking that way online being
uncovered and shamed for the public view
The Daily Beast dug up who this guy was
and then proceeded to spill his all his
details on the Internet I said Brooks a
34 year old day laborer currently on
probation after pleading guilty to
domestic battery claims that his drunk
commentary on an unaltered Pelosi video
had no connection to the now infamous
fake clip that premiered less than 15
minutes later I wasn't the individual
who created that Pelosi video he
insisted in a telephone interview it's
conceivable that someone else actually
edited the clip but a Facebook official
confirming a Daily Beast investigation
said the video was first posted on
politics watchdog directly from Brooks's
personal Facebook account so now I have
a question why is Facebook answering
that question from The Daily Beast if
The Daily Beast goes to Facebook and
says I want the identity
whomever published his video why is
Facebook reviewing that identity the guy
didn't commit a crime
the guy didn't involve himself in
slander or libel how in the world is it
facebook's job to answer questions from
The Daily Beast about the source of this
sort of video and how is it not an act
of tremendous nastiness and evil for The
Daily Beast to report on this guy's
criminal record
because he committed the grave crime of
making fun of Nancy Pelosi online Brooks
acknowledged he's involved in the
management of both politics watchdog and
all news 24/7 the Facebook pages that
sent the bogus video on its viral tear
to the outside observer the two pages
are unconnected but after a telltale
link on one of the pages led The Daily
Beast to Brooks he admitted the ad
revenue for both outlets goes directly
into his personal PayPal account in the
first sense and a possible motive for
the Pelosi smear Brooks volunteered that
the video brought in nearly a thousand
dollars in shared ad revenue so it
wasn't that he disliked Pelosi is that
he was seeking to make a nefarious cash
off of this doctored altered video okay
then I have a question what does the
media do every day when they dr. video
when I say dr. buddy I don't mean slow
things down I mean when they cut things
out of context let's say how much money
to the media make off the Covington
Catholic boys smear how much I bet it
was not a thousand dollars I bet you it
is hundreds of thousands or millions of
dollars in additional links in views in
ads how much money to the media make off
taking president Trump out of context or
taking me out of context or taking any
conservative out of context and then
pretending as though they have covered
the news so it is their motive to make
money or is their motive to cover the
news and they happen to be biased the
number would have been higher said
Brooks except that Facebook cut off any
future earnings when the company's
fact-check partners ruled the clip as a
hoax about 36 hours after its politics
watchdog debut it makes money for
Facebook to he grouse I'm sure that's
the motive for not taking it down over
the course of an hour and a half
interview Brooks insisted repeatedly he
was not the one who posted the Pelosi
clip on politics watchdog he claimed
he's just one of half a dozen
administrators who jointly control the
page and his content it was one of the
others he said he debuted the doctor
videos a female admin who posted it so
if he's not lying if the guy's not lying
not only to The Daily Beast out this guy
with a criminal record but then they got
it wrong I mean this is I don't know how
the media
justify this sort of stuff a review of
Brooks's personal fanpage reveals him as
an avowed conservative and a proud
member of trumps razor-thin
african-american support base yeah
there's some solid journalism there
trumps razor-thin so that means that
he's a weirdo obviously I'm in this guy
a couple of Brooks's Instagram post
feature misogyny the strongest example
is a post last year featuring a photo he
evidently snapped above a woman sitting
next to him on the subway this dumb B
word sitting in front of me on the e
trend continues to kick me without
saying excuse me
he wrote Wow well I mean obviously we
need to uncover everything this person
has never said he posted a mean video of
Nancy Pelosi this Rando published a mean
video of Nancy Pelosi just like hundreds
of thousands of other people probably
have done her scene we must out him and
then we must dig through everything he
has ever said and then we must destroy
his life but don't worry The Daily Beast
has you covered as far as his personal
likes in football I kid you not
according to The Daily Beast
he runs other pages as well an ardent
New England Patriots fan Brooks has a
long history of AMA adventures around
athletics including a Facebook page
called outkick the sports Brooks has
sparked LinkedIn profile lists him as an
analyst at sports blogger a long
shuttered blog platform where's Brooks
once blogged under his current Twitter
screen named sports guru sir he says I'm
in New York City very liberal people
make judgments I don't want to be linked
to a conservative right winger and be
potentially denied services and stuff
people are nasty you should see some of
the messages that are coming in weird
you know I was told by the left that if
I quoted Ilhan Omar that was incitement
to violence
if the daily B's posted all of this
guy's personal details for the grave sin
of having published an anonymous video
slowed down of Nancy Pelosi seeming
drunk well then that's not incite Minh
in any way that's just I'm covering the
news guys that is them doing all the
news that's fit to print over at The
Daily Beast Brooks said that he became a
conservative after seeing firsthand the
failure of liberal policies during the
Obama era he said I've traveled around
and seen too many things I don't like
the way things have been run a key
turning point came years ago he said
when he was working in a warehouse in
Queens doing forklift work loading
unloading and labeling he started the
job off the books but eventually became
an official hire then the managers began
supplementing their workforce with
undocumented immigrants willing to do
the same work for less
he claimed he said I was working there
four or five years and I was being paid
pretty well then suddenly they started
bringing these guys in vans
through the side door this was going on
for months then all of a sudden they
told me we can't pay you anymore since
then he's taken up a bunch of temporary
jobs and he showed up in California he
crashed a girlfriend's Riverside
apartment for about a month and then
they went they found the girl and she
said we got into apartments we got into
arguments and fights all the time he has
a lot of issues going on here's a lot of
anger issues
this piece is thousands of words long
because a man posted a video of Nancy
Pelosi sounding drunk this is insanity
this is how journalism works in the
trump era seriously and then we're
supposed to respect the media we're
supposed to pretend that the media are
really doing the hard work of uncovering
the truth this is what they spend their
time doing there's when Noah shaft Minh
over at The Daily Beast is doing these
days they some good reporters over at
the Daily Beast by the way Lachlan
Marquis is a good reporter over at The
Daily Beast but this guy is not and the
fact that The Daily Beast sees this as
its mission is pretty astonishing at
least part of its mission I'll show you
what the editor of The Daily Beast had
to say over the weekend about this
nonsense first father stays right around
the corner 23andme z' health and
ancestry kid is the perfect gift for a
limited time get 50 bucks off a 23andme
health and ancestry kit through June
17th if you buy a kit for yourself - you
and Dad can connect celebrate your
shared genetic similarities and
differences with over 125 personalized
genetic reports on health traits and
more 23andme is a lot of fun I've gotten
my 23andme report it gives you all sorts
of information that's not just where you
came from
it also has all of this information
about your health and your history give
dad a gift as unique as he is he can
discover how genes influences well-being
and lifestyle choices with insights into
genetic weight muscle composition sleep
quality and more give dad a gift that's
insightful trait traits reports give
insights into how genetics can affect
mosquito bite frequency motion sickness
fear of heights and more give dad the
gift of discovery he can explore where
his DNA is from out of over a thousand
regions worldwide with the most
comprehensive genetic ancestry breakdown
on the market this Father's Day get 50
bucks off 23 amis health and ancestry
kit at 23andme comm slash Shapiro find
out if you are more Native American than
Elizabeth Warren that's the number two
three-and me.com slash Shapiro again
that's 23andme comm slash Shapiro offer
ends June 17th go check them out right
now
that is two three and me.com slash
Shapiro 23andme comm slash repair that
offer ends at June 17th all right so
Noah Sackman
over at The Daily Beast
appeared unreliable sources on CNN with
brian Stelter and Schekman defended
their choice to run this several
thousand word piece about the terrible
evil horrible forklift operator who made
a video of Nancy Pelosi slightly slowed
down so that she sounded drunk there's a
profit motive here that you can put up a
lot of these videos on Facebook you can
make a quick buck didn't this guy say he
made a thousand dollars yeah I mean look
that's not it might have been a lot of
money to him but I don't think it was a
pure profit motive I think for him it
was a matter of ideology it was you know
he's a big Trump supporter and you know
one of the most interesting things about
this story to me was that you know you
don't need some sophisticated operation
in order to publish fake news or
publisher hoaxes they'll grab the
country's attention
Wow so important we didn't know that
before you know nobody had ever posted
anything on Facebook that was flawed or
fake news or or skewed in any way we
needed to uncover this guy we need to
shame him and we needed to get his mug
shot and put it up there on the Internet
deeply important that we ruin his future
employment history so that we can show
that fake news appears you wonder why
people are angry at the media because
the media did nothing for years while
Barack Obama's administration was deeply
corrupt at a variety of levels and now
they are digging up personal material on
private citizens who post videos on
Facebook that is why people are angry at
people in the media now I'm for a lot of
the media scrutiny of the Trump
administration I wish they'd done it
during the Obama administration to my
critique is not that they are hard on
Trump my critique is that they were easy
on Obama but there's one thing that I
really dislike and that is the idea that
if regular citizens take part in
politics then now they're going to be
raked over the coals in the same way as
somebody who's running for elected
office it's really disgusting it really
is I mean and these places do do it for
cliques it's funny there is a website a
few weeks ago that in the midst of one
of my numerous controversies because
every week seems to be a controversy now
in the midst of one of the numerous
controversies surrounding me decided to
post a piece the top five things you
need to know about my wife my wife is a
private citizen my wife does not
participate in politics she votes that's
it my wife does not give speeches at my
wife does
appear publicly my wife is a private
citizen and this website printed a bunch
of facts about my wife including where
she works they printed a bunch of facts
about her including where she'd gone to
high school and all the rest of this
stuff and there's only one purpose for
that to satiate curiosity to get clicks
and to expose her to public scrutiny now
listen the people at my wife's work know
exactly who her husband is
many of her patients know exactly who my
wife is but the fact that this website
saw fit to make my wife an issue is
insane to their credit we called them up
and we said this is inappropriate and
they pulled it down but the first
instinct for many in the media is to get
those clicks while they're accusing this
guy of being clickbait motivated you
think Daily Beast isn't clickbait
motivated they certainly are and there's
another agenda here too and that is to
rip on these big tech companies and try
to promote their leftism what we are
seeing now from both right and left is
an attempt to grab the means of
production so Facebook is an independent
means of distribution and people on the
Left are fighting mad that because so
many people get their news from Facebook
they're fighting mad they can't control
this and this is why you saw Nancy
Pelosi say last week that Facebook
willingly willingly promotes lies about
her which is why they willingly promoted
lies about Hillary Clinton which is why
Hillary Clinton is not president this is
her way of claiming that the government
and Democrats in particular should take
control of major social media pages in
order to cure the dialog
whenever somebody talks about curing or
purifying the dialog get ready for your
First Amendment rights to be to be
infringed upon here's Nancy Pelosi
making that case facebook says I know
this is false but we're it's a lie but
we're showing it anyway I was giving
them the benefit they're down on Russia
but clearly they I thought it was
unwitting but clearly they wittingly
were accomplices and enablers of false
information to go across Facebook yeah
well this is just a I mean she's lying
she's lying
Facebook was not willingly an accomplice
to the Russians it's a platform they put
up lots of stuff this is one of the
things that I've been arguing is that
Facebook needs to stay a platform and
not become a Nancy Pelosi driven
editorial board the reason that
Democrats are complaining about this
stuff the reason they're trying to
uncover people is because what they
actually wanted to
many members of the media hope to do is
stop people from speaking out
politically what they hope to do is turn
Facebook into just another New York
Times editorial page this is what they
would like to see and by the way this is
not restricted to the left
president Trump unfortunately has the
same sort of tendencies so President
Trump tweeted out this morning quote
just arrived in the United Kingdom the
only problem is that CNN is the primary
source of news in from news available
from the United States after watching it
for a short while I turned it off all
negative and so much fake news very bad
for us big ratings drop
why doesn't owner AT&T do something I
believe that if people stopped using or
subscribing to AT&T they'll be forced to
make big changes at CNN which is dying
in the ratings anyway it is so unfair
with such bad news fake news why
wouldn't they act when the world watches
CNN it gets a false picture of us a sad
Alice I think CNN puts out an awful lot
of misinformation or at lea at the very
least biased information but the
President of the United States
suggesting that the owner AT&T should
crack down on the editorial viewpoint of
CNN does not seem like a good move to me
and we have seen the same thing from
President Trump with regard to Amazon so
there's been this push from the Trump
administration to go after Amazon for
violation of antitrust as I've said
before I don't think that Amazon is in
violation of antitrust law they are not
effectively a monopoly there are lots of
other companies in the various spaces in
which Amazon participates Amazon is
certainly not a monopoly from the
consumer point of view the danger of
monopoly from the consumer point of view
was is and always will be that monopoly
racks up giant prices that they gouge
consumers because they're the only
producers in the market if you're the
only producer of a good in the market
you're the only person producing cameras
in the market you can then charge 1
million dollars per camera and no one
can compete with you because you bought
everybody else out or force them out or
crowded them out of the market or you've
participated in some form of regulatory
capture that has prevented anyone else
from entering the market that is not the
case with Amazon the fact that the Trump
administration is seeking to crack down
on Amazon I can't help but believe that
it has something to do with the fact
that Donald Trump does not like Jeff
Bezos so in the same way that the left
doesn't like Facebook because they think
that Facebook led Hillary Clinton to
lose Donald Trump doesn't like Amazon
because he doesn't like Jeff Bezos and
Beezus also operates the Washington Post
according to the San Francisco Chronicle
Amazon could face heightened antitrust
scrutiny under a new agreement between
US regulators that puts it under closer
watch by the Federal Trade Commission
three people familiar with the matter
said the move is the result of the FTC
and the Department of Justice the US
government's leading antitrust
enforcement agencies quietly divvying up
competition oversight of two of the
country's top tech companies according
to those people who spoke on condition
of anonymity the Justice Department is
set to have more jurisdiction over
Google The Washington Post reported on
Friday paving the way for a potential
investigation of the search and
advertising giant so they're now looking
to put Google under the thumb they're
also looking to put Amazon under the
thumb very interesting article from The
Wall Street Journal today about Google
explaining that while the Justice
Department is now looking at Google as a
monopoly Google is losing market share
here's the Wall Street Journal reports
today the irony that surely won't
register in Washington the latest
crackdown on Google comes just as the
Internet giant is demonstrating that it
is far from invincible the Justice
Department is preparing a new antitrust
investigation against Google parent
alphabet Inc this comes six years after
a similar probe from the Federal Trade
Commission which resulted in no
significant damage to the company that
powers more than 90% of the world's
internet search activity Google's
dominance of internet search and related
advertising business make it an easy
target the company Garner's more than 60
percent of the world's search ad market
according to eMarketer its total
advertising business has averaged 19
percent growth annually over the past
decade analysts expect advertising
revenue to surpass 135 billion dollars
this year which is almost twice the size
of its nearest competitor Facebook yet
recent developments have demonstrated
that even Google isn't invulnerable
alphabets most recent quarterly showing
results showed a significant and
surprising slowdown in Google's ad
business that hurt the stock investors
found the companies clumsy explanation
on satisfactory Amazon is emerging as a
potent advertising force in its own
right as the company is now charging
merchants for favorable placement on its
massive online marketplace Amazon
generated eleven billion dollars in
revenue for its other category that is
primarily composed of advertising for
the trailing 12-month period ending in
March analysts predicted Amazon's had
business is going to more than double in
size and it will come at Google's
expense also Google's dominance in
search has not translated to other
businesses that
company has entered its pixel smartphone
has less than 1% of the global market
Google trails both Amazon and Microsoft
by a wide margin in the fast-growing
market for cloud computing services in
other words all the talk about Google
being a monopoly is simply not the case
I'll talk about Amazon being a monopoly
is simply not the case here's the
problem they're a bunch of people at the
governmental level and in the media or
very much interested in controlling
other folks controlling other companies
it's bad news you do not want these
folks controlling your life I would
rather have open competition between
companies that are run by people with
whom I disagree companies run by
Zuckerberg companies run by the Eric
Schmidt's of the world over an alphabet
Inc I'd rather have that than to have it
run by regulators then have it run by
members of the government because here's
the thing once the government takes
control of these companies do you really
trust that the government is going to
run these in fair and impartial fashion
if you think that's the case remember
when the government was in the Fairness
Doctrine business and decided that today
we're going to operate how much
conservative content could be put on
your radio I know for those not old
enough to have a radio this was the
thing the fact is that the government in
control of these businesses is a bad
thing but that's what Democrats want if
Democrats want something you can fairly
certainly predict that Republicans
should not want it the fact that both
Republicans and Democrats are now buying
for control over major tech companies I
think it's pretty scary
and it's fairly unamerican okay in a
second we're gonna get to the culture
war and the 2020 Democratic fight for
the nomination first let's talk about
something we can all agree on saving
money the reality is if you're not
shopping around you're probably not
saving money so what if there was a way
for somebody to do the shopping around
for you mm-hmm well that's exactly what
honey does honey is a free tool that you
download to your computer's browser
well you shop online honey scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts and automatically applies the
coupon with the biggest savings to your
cart at checkout just like magic it
takes zero effort to install just two
clicks you're ready to start saving any
time you shop online there's really no
reason not to use honey it's free to use
easy to install on your computer and
just two clicks don't take it from me
take it from our listeners get honey for
free at join honey calm slash pen that
is join honey calm slash button honey
it's the smart shopping assistant that
saves you time and money I use honey
every time I shop and it saves me money
nearly every time I shop whether I am
shopping for diapers for my kid or
whether I am shopping for anything else
I am always saving money with honey and
you can to go to join honey calm slash
pen doesn't cost you anything
you just have it run in the background
in your computer and you're gonna save
money every time that's join honey calm
/ mind if not every time nearly every
time honey it's the smart shopping
assistant that saves you time and money
okay so let's talk about this 2020
Democratic race the Democrats have to
rely on how much President Trump is
supposedly hated now there's a new
Harvard poll out today that shows
president Trump's approval rating up to
48% if President Trump is at 48% in the
approval rating come election 2020 he
retains the presidency it is that simple
if he is anywhere within spitting
distance of 50% he will win if he is
anywhere close to 40% he will probably
lose
so what President Trump does from here
on in is very important and how radical
Democrats are from here on in is also
very important so how radical are
Democrats they are the base is really
radical but there's the silent majority
of the Democratic Party or at least
plurality of the Democratic Party that
is not nearly as radical as the base and
that gap is beginning to be felt and I'm
wondering whether the silent plurality
of the Democratic base can withstand the
pressure from the left-wing because now
it's breaking out into the open I said
for a long time I thought that the best
day for Joe Biden was gonna be his first
day well that hasn't been true he's had
a lot of good days since then but could
it be the the best couple of months for
Biden come at the very beginning that
certainly could be the case now you want
to know where the energy is in the
Democratic Party it is with the wild
left wing there's a Democratic candidate
for the presidency who is so obscure we
haven't even created a theme song for
him yet named John Delaney and John
Delaney was speaking at the California
convention which is sort of grounds
Ground Zero for the Democratic Party
he's a businessman who is running for
president he was the US Representative
for Maryland's sixth congressional
district from 2013 to 2019 you've never
heard of him because he was just a
random Congress person well here he was
explaining that he is not Pro socialism
and getting booed for his trouble
Democrats to build an economy that works
but it's got to be with smart policies
medicare-for-all may sound good but it's
actually not good
nor is it good politics I'm telling you
we should have universal health care
we should have universal health care but
it shouldn't be a kind of health care
that kicks 150 million Americans off
their health care that's not smart
policy okay he's getting booed this is
the best moment John Cellini has ever
had or will ever have
he should be campaigning on this if he
did you know how many votes he would get
inside the Democratic Party a hell of a
lot more than all of the jokers who are
running to the far left of the
Democratic Party but you can see where
the energy is in the Democratic Party
the easiest way to see where people
think the energy is in the Democratic
Party is to follow Kirsten Gillibrand
because Kirsten Gillibrand basically
she's a pander machine she's a panda
bear that's all she does I mean she
changes her positions routinely she's
got her finger in the wind all the time
and so she is constantly taking the
position she thinks will be most
beneficial to her when she first ran for
Senate in New York she was fairly
pro-gun she was somewhat pro-life and
now she switched all of her positions
because that's where she believes that
the money is in the Democratic Party
that's where she believes the enthusiasm
is in the Democratic Party so here she
was over the weekend Kirsten Gillibrand
the the bellwether for the Democratic
Party the weathervane for the Democratic
Party explaining that she is very much
in favor of third trimester abortion are
you saying also then her late term so I
support roe v-- wade okay roe v-- wade
is the settled Supreme Court precedent
that decides the entire issue and so I
support roe v wade I believe it should
be codified it's been law of the land
for over 30 years it should be law of
the land as president the United States
I will repeal the Hyde Amendment it's
the amendment in law that makes it
impossible for low-income women to
access the care they need I will make
sure no matter what state you live in
you have access to reproductive care
including abortion services and there
she is defending third trimester
abortion she also attacked Fox News she
understands this is where the enthusiasm
is the Democrats understand the game
right now right which is you go on Fox
News and you rip into Fox News which
frankly is is pretty smart but they all
understand that even treating people on
Fox News as though they are human is a
bad idea this is this is one of the
things that I think has driven the right
absolutely off its rocker
I mean driven us mad is this notion from
the left that
I disagree with you I'm not a human
being I have conversations with people
on the left all the time I'm trying to
reach out to people on the left on a
regular basis I really do have
conversations with folks with whom I
disagree on a regular basis the
unwillingness of many on the left to
grant the humanity of people who
disagree with them is a truly crucial
and terrible thing here is Kirsten
Gillibrand appealing to precisely that
instinct by ripping on Fox News before
President Trump gave his State of the
Union Fox News talked about infanticide
there's an aside it does exist
senator I just want to say we brought
you here for an hour we have given you
we're waiting you very fairly I
understand that maybe to make your
credentials with the with the Democrats
who are not appearing on Fox News you're
going to attack us I'm not sure it's
frankly very polite when okay I will do
it in a polite way
but it's well I just I just why don't we
instead of talking about Fox News why
don't you answer Sue's question okay so
she again knows where her bread is
better than this is sort of the point
you see the same thing from Kamala
Harris who is who is pandering to the
far left
she says all women have the right to do
whatever they want with their own bodies
this is of course her speaking at a
Planned Parenthood event over the
weekend to make sure that every woman
has the right to do whatever she chooses
to do so the enthusiasm in the
Democratic Party is far to the left
another example from Kirsten Gillibrand
I do find this amusing so she just
flat-out lies about the NRA over the
weekends there's this terrible shooting
in Virginia Beach it was apparently done
by a disgruntled employee some of the 12
people are killed and she goes after the
NRA hard as Kirsten Gillibrand there's
only one problem which I will explain
momentarily is there anything you could
have done that would have stopped this
terrible incident yeah
stop being beholden to the NRA like
president Trump is he does president
Trump's bidding remember after the
shooting in Las Vegas he said yeah yeah
we're gonna ban the bum stocks DD BAM
the bump sucks no because the NRA came
crashing down and said don't you dare do
any restrictions on
around this country it is such a false
choice the NRA is lying to the American
people it is not about the Second
Amendment
it is about gun sales it is literally
about greed and corruption okay this is
such a lie and it is also indicative of
who Kirsten Gillibrand is letter from
Kirsten Gillibrand September 19 2008
Chris Cox executive director of the NRA
dear Kris thank you again for meeting
with me before the August recess even
though we discussed many of my positions
regarding Second Amendment issues I
wanted to provide you with a more full
description of my beliefs on this issue
to begin with I want to be very clear I
always haven't always will believe that
the correct of interpretation of the
Second Amendment is that it applies to
an individual's right to carry guns and
does not apply generally to the National
Guard or group of individuals in a state
on the question of outright banning
certain firearms for cosmetic features
bullets of a random size or banning
magazines holding an arbitrary number of
cartridges I'm adamantly opposed and do
not believe that laws should be based on
random limits just for the sake of
limiting gun ownership and usage in
addition this development of smart guns
that can be fired only by their owner as
an intriguing idea but I'm afraid that
mandating such technologies will harm
consumers ability to use their guns in
emergency situations and then she
concludes this letter she says I
appreciate the work that the NRA does to
protect gun owners rights I look forward
to working with you for many years in
Congress I incur stand Gillibrand member
of Congress as from about 11 years ago
now of course she has flipped on the NRA
and the NRA is deeply evil all of which
prompted Chris Wallace to say to her
lady you switch her positions more often
than the kamasutra recommends your
campaign slogan is brave wins yep but
when you were a congresswoman
representing a conservative district in
upstate New York
you took pretty conservative positions
on guns and immigration once you became
the senator for the entire liberal state
of New York you flipped and took much
more liberal positions on guns and
migration so how is that brave it's
because I came from a district that was
really rural Second Amendment was
important hunting was important my mom
of course she cooked the Thanksgiving
turkey but she also shot the
Thanksgiving turkey okay so that is her
explaining that she switched all of her
positions so solid response that for
Christian Bell
Gillibrand the point here being that
Gillibrand is a great indicator of where
she thinks the arrows are pointing in
the Democratic Party and they are
pointing in the Bernie Sanders direction
not the Joe Biden direction I'll get
some more of that in just one second
first let me tell you about this helix
sleep mattress that I've got at my house
it is just fantastic
every night I live me down to sleep on
that helix sleep mattress and my
goodness it's like being in heaven it's
just great helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences so the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by GQ and Wired magazine CNN called it
the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on mat maybe the first time
CNN has ever told the truth just go to
helix sleep calm / men take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
four couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 125 bucks
off at helix sleep calm / Ben that's
helix sleep calm / Ben for up to 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleep calm / Ben go check them out right
now helix sleep calm / Ben alrighty so
we're going to get into Joe Biden who's
basically it's it's Crouching Joe hidden
Biden that's what that's what's become
he's hiding out somewhere he basically
has taken my advice which is that if he
just goes away and hides in a hole for a
year and a half he could be President of
the United States that's basically what
Joe Biden is up to we'll get to that in
just one second Plus Elizabeth Warren
joining the Panda Express but first
you're gonna have to go and subscribe
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
daily we're calm when you do you get the
rest of this show live you get two
additional hours of the show every day
which is us working really hard to bring
you additional content also because we
broadcast this show in the morning and
then we broadcast again in the afternoon
you got my commentary on events
basically all day every day so you get
that plus you get the Andrew Klavan show
and the Matt Walsh show and if for some
reason you're incredibly bored to have
nothing better to do the Michael Noel's
show as well I get all those things when
you subscribe for $99 a year you also
get this leftist here's how to call
tumblr view it cast your eyes upon it be
astonished by its beauty
the leftist chairs hot or cold
or go check that out right now I also
want to remind you the importance of you
subscribing when you subscribe it helps
insulate programs like this one from the
vicissitudes of the of the nasty cusses
over places like Media Matters
or constantly seeking to drive this show
into the ground we're constantly seeking
to thought police everyone who disagrees
with them when you subscribe become part
of the team and we really do appreciate
it it is you joining up with the
conservative movement in a really a
serious real material way so please I'm
telling you I think it's important
please go subscribe over at daily
wire.com I get that annual subscription
become part of the team we really do
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so let's talk for a second
about a little more pandering on the
part of the Democrats I've played you
some kirsten gillibrand who knows where
where the party is going I played you
some Kamala Harris I thought the most
pandering most pandering move of the
weekend had to come from Elizabeth
Warren so now it is Pride Month LGBTQIA
a cube Z Pride Month and all right
whatever but she tweets out a video of
herself in the most Awkward possible way
if she is just Hillary Clinton on akward
steroids she's like mm Mark McGwire was
a big strong guy before he started
taking steroid and then he started
taking steroids and he sort of exploded
well the same thing has happened to
Elizabeth Warren she was an awkward
person before she ran for president and
now she's taking the awkward steroids
and she's exploding like Marvel Mark
McGwire she's breaking Roger Maris's
record in terms of awkwardness if you
can't see this video it is her wearing a
rainbow feather boa that she must have
picked up at some sort of Halloween shop
and she's walking around high-fiving
people with extraordinary enthusiasm
that nobody else in the crowd seems to
share she tweeted out hashtag Pride
Month is a celebration it's a time to
remember the trailblazers who fought for
lgbtq+ civil rights today and every day
we renew our commitment to fight until
everyone can live proudly without fear
I'll be right there alongside you happy
hashtag pride okay so quick note this is
America 2019 I lived in Los Angeles not
a lot of gay folks who are not living
without pride lots of gay folks who are
living quite openly as is their
prerogative in a free society I don't
really see what exactly she is
suggesting the changes but in any case
there she is being super awkward she
knows where the future of the Democratic
Party lies it lies with the radical left
let's see how she does in the middle of
the country and with voters who may not
be her own by the way it's this sort of
social issue pandering that is leading
to one of the great divides in the
country at large we'll get to that in
just a minute first I want to talk a
little bit about Joe Biden so the guns
are finally starting to open up on Joe
Biden from the left side of the aisle
according to the Associated Press all
the 20 20 Democratic presidential
campaigns show up in California to
pander Joe Biden does not why well maybe
he's afraid that he's going to say what
John Zeleny said and then get booed
according to the AP Democratic
presidential hopefuls took rival Joe
bide
absence at a California State Party
gathering Saturday as a chance to take
subtle digs at the former VP and craft
themselves is better position to bring
Democrats into the future Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren said quote some
say if we all just calm down the
Republicans will come to their senses
apparently this was a reference to
Biden's comments that the GOP may have
an epiphany after Trump is gone but our
country is in a crisis the time for
small ideas is over ah she wasn't the
only one to be saying stuff like this
Gavin Newsom said Joe Biden is very
familiar to Californians he spends a
great deal of time in California but of
course he has also endorsed Kamala
Harris the senator from California Pete
Budaj edge the mayor of South Bend
Indiana who governs the city smaller
than what one twentieth of my Twitter
following he says the riskiest thing we
can do is play it safe there's no going
back to normal
representative Eric swallow who's
running the most bizarre campaign for
president I have ever seen in my life he
referenced Joe Biden he said we don't
need a crime bill we need a hope bill I
don't even know what the hell a hope
bill would look like that was a hope
bill I'm just I'm confused what policy
that is apparently Warren and New Jersey
Senator Cory Booker received the most
enthusiastic response from the crowd
Warren reprised her I've got a plan for
that slogan and Cory Booker talked about
how evil guns are beta O'Rourke spoke
also basically everybody kind of took
subtle digs at Biden I think those break
out into the open in pretty short order
and the New York Times is leading the
way they've got a long piece today title
Biden's first run for president was a
calamity some missteps still resonate
they say in 1988 Joe Biden was prone to
embellishment hints of that linger today
but unlike then his message to voters is
clear he's a stabilizing statement
statesmen in a tumultuous time and they
talk about all of the all of the lies
that your Biden told back when he was
running for president in 1988 and they
talk about how Biden still has a has a
tendency to exaggerate and all the rest
of this as I say I think that it was
only a matter of time until the
Democrats opened up on Biden and once
they opened up on Biden we'll see how
well he withstands the assault
especially because I don't think that
Joe Biden has a lot of taste for going
up against the radicals inside his own
party eventually he's going to be put to
a choice is he gonna
with the radicals with the Kamala
Harrises with the Elizabeth Warren's
with the Bernie Sanders is he gonna try
and co-opt them or is he gonna stand
strong against them and if he tries to
co-opt them if he tries to move into
their Lane how long before they start to
chip away at him because after all
Elizabeth Warren is a more eloquent
expositor of far left is ax men Joe
Biden who is not actually on the far
left in terms of most of his policies
meanwhile I think this is worthy of note
not because anything Taylor Swift does
is ever really worthy of note but
because it isn't here's what I mean so
apparently Taylor Swift has now publicly
rejected president Trump's stance on
LGBTQ rights in a letter to Senator
Lamar Alexander now you'll remember that
Taylor Swift tried to endorse a
Tennessee gubernatorial candidate a
couple of years ago or last year in the
gubernatorial race and that ended up
being a giant fail for her nobody cared
what Taylor's who have thought about
politics that is not stopping her but
here is what the Washington Post reports
today Taylor Swift's newfound political
streak was on full display Saturday when
she posted to Instagram a lengthy letter
to senator Lamar Alexander of Tennessee
imploring him to protect LGBTQ rights by
voting to support the Equality Act the
Act which was passed by the house last
month would ban discrimination based on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in employment housing education jury
service and Federal Financing will do a
lot more than that it would basically
mandate that if you are a private person
in private life that you have to imbibe
everything that the social Left tells
you about the malleability of gender of
sexual orientation of all of that stuff
so it said I've decided to kick off
Pride Month by writing a letter to one
of my senators to explain how strongly I
feel that the Equality Act should be
passed I urge you to write to your
Senators to I'll be looking for your
letters by searching the hashtag letter
to my senator in the letter she wrote
for American citizens to be denied jobs
or housing based on who they love or how
they identify in my opinion is
unamerican and cruel she added that some
argue the actus Rupp's religious freedom
there are hundreds of Tennessee faith
leaders who have recently disagreed and
spoken out to defend the LGBTQ community
which is not an argument that's an
argument that if you are a traditional
Christian who believes in traditional
values about sin and sex that you should
basically be disregarded because she
found some liberal pastors who echo her
viewpoint
she wrote that protecting the LGBTQ
community from discrimination could
bring more job
to Tennessee citing the fact that
several corporations including Amazon
have spoken out against the anti LGBTQ
slate of hate referring to bills moving
through the state legislature that would
according to Human Rights Campaign allow
businesses organizations and contractors
to discriminate against LGBTQ people in
employment policies first of all that
sort of language demonstrates the
overreach that people want from
government okay it's not about allowing
businesses to discriminate if it's a
private business the question is does
the government have a right to interfere
in private business not what will they
allow businesses to do you do not get
your writ from the government this is
not 17th century Britain free
association freedom to pursue your
business in way you see fit is a basic
American right freedom of this has
nothing to with free religion religious
freedom really it has to do with freedom
of association if you don't want to have
to hire a conservative for your business
this would be a you thing and if I don't
feel like hiring somebody from the left
from my business this would be a me
thing and if I'm a religious institution
that doesn't feel like violating my own
religious precepts by performing a
same-sex marriage
that's a me thing and if you don't feel
like accepting somebody from my
synagogue into your church that's a you
thing you know how we can all live in
society together we can lighten the eff
up and leave each other alone that's
what we can do but Taylor Swift is
writing this letter now why does it
matter the Taylor Swift and all these
celebrities write these letters and the
left wants to play this double game the
double game is this every time the right
complains about a cultural figure
intervening in politics people almost
say well why do you care they're
citizens just like anyone else what do
you what are you whining about why do
you you mean you say you don't care
about celebrity why does it matter to
you what Taylor Swift has to say but
then they tried out all these people at
the DNC
because they obviously believe that
these people have something to say so
here's what has happened and it's really
bad for the country because the cultural
has now become political because there
is no element of American culture that
is free from politics or at least mildly
free from politics because every aspect
of American culture has become more and
more political from Gillette ads to
sports because every because every movie
must be replete with social justice
warrior messaging he's everything from
children's book to library time has
become a battleground for social issues
what's happened is that the right feels
like it's not in control of the culture
and the right is correct the right is
not in control of the culture the people
in Hollywood
universally to the left so universally
to the left that people in Hollywood it
is far far harder in Hollywood to be a
conservative than it is to be gay there
is no question about that it's just
really I mean I know many people in
Hollywood many of whom are gay and many
of whom are conservative and many of
whom are both there's no question it is
harder to come out of the closet as a
conservative in Hollywood than it is to
be gay in Hollywood to take an example
and this is why I've had Hollywood
people who are friends who high place
people in the Hollywood industry and
every time I meet with them or get
together with them I will overtly
explain to them that they should never
reveal to the public that we have met
because they will be destroyed by their
own folks the commanding heights of the
culture are run by the left and Taylor
Swift proves it and Taylor Swift who was
silence for you there was a meme online
a joke online
why doesn't Taylor Swift speak out about
this issue her silence is deafening
because basically she was apolitical and
she didn't say anything about politics
then in the last couple of years her SJW
friends convinced her that it was time
for her to speak out about politics and
now she won't shut up about politics
well people on the right feeling like
they are not in control of the culture
then move to the realm of government for
protection so they pour all of their
energies not into culture and not into
the culture war and pour all of their
energies into politics because this is
something that they understand we can
put our money behind candidates and not
only that whenever there is a cultural
figure with any sort of cachet who
endorses the right-wing position people
on the right freak out because like wow
there's finally someone in the culture
who doesn't disdain us and sneer at us
it's a major reason Donald Trump is
president Donald Trump was a cultural
figure not a political one but he was a
cultural figure who did not sneer and
everybody who is on the right and the
right was so flattered by this that they
thought oh wow somebody who actually is
willing to fight the culture wars the
left meanwhile has ratcheted up the
cultural battles and so people on the
right have reacted by saying okay well
we're going to elect politicians who at
least are not going to kowtow to Lena
Dunham out in Los Angeles in New York
we're going to elect people who
fervently wish to ignore Taylor Swift
and the left has responded by saying
okay well if we don't have political
power will ratchet up our cultural power
as the left takes over the culture and
the right moves back into politics what
you are getting is this massive war
the political class on the left has
merged with the cultural class and the
same thing is happening on the right so
politics and culture are becoming two
sides of the same coin
and it's really not good for the country
it used to be that the cultural sphere
is where we all got together to chat
during work breaks and now we can't even
do that anymore
and it's leading to political divides
too because if all of our culture is
political and all of our politics is
cultural what do we share we didn't use
to share politics but at least we shared
culture now we don't share politics or
culture and things I think are getting
to a breaking point that's why this sort
of stuff from Taylor Swift or Reese
Witherspoon's sounding off about
abortion that's why this matters it's
only a matter of time before the United
States has two separate cultures there's
no cultural space that is shared either
that's not gonna be good for the country
the left is pushing it so that there
will have to be two different business
lines in every business people who
decide to endorse the social justice
warrior left the Gillette's of the world
and people who do not people who
endorsed the Starbucks view of the world
and people who endorsed the black rifle
coffee view of the world that's where
the politics of the country is going I
don't think it's good for the country
but it is quickly becoming a reality
and that's because the left could not
leave the culture alone they decided to
ratchet up the cultural control that the
left you utilizes on a regular basis
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today so number one I've
gotten comfort food for me is westerns
westerns are just great I've gotten into
watching some some old westerns recently
so this happened because you know a
couple of weeks ago I was just looking
for some movie comfort food and I came
up with tombstone which is just
fantastic and then I thought okay well
what are some of the best westerns I've
never seen well at the very top of the
list was John Ford's My Darling
Clementine so John Ford one of the great
directors in American film history
directed at least 12 films that are
actual honest-to-goodness classics well
one of them is My Darling Clementine
which was one of the first movies about
Doc Holliday and Wyatt Earp maybe the
first major film about Doc Holliday and
Wyatt Earp stars Henry Fonda and Linda
Darnell and Victor Mature and it really
is a good movie also the use of the
camera is pretty fantastic apparently
this is one of the movies that that was
you
realized by Orson Welles is sort of a
model for for how he'd like to use the
camera John Ford is really an underrated
director in his use of the camera here's
a little bit of the trailer for My
Darling Clementine shave please what
what you want to thank you mr. earth
Wyatt er what you're not by any chance
the Marshall from Dodge City ex Marshall
what are you doing up here
none of your business why don't you
behave yourself go on get out go on back
for you I'm not leaving till she gets
out of town so one of the things about
the movie that's kind of fun all of the
other Larry bunch movies about Wyatt
Earp and Doc Holliday and all of the
movies are basically dependent on the
relationship between Doc Holliday and
Wyatt Earp and this one Victor Mature
who is considered kind of a beefcake at
the time and not much of an actor he
actually turns in a very good
performance as Doc Holliday and the
contrast between Victor Mature and Henry
Fonda in this in this movie is quite
good they changed the story obviously
tombstone is a much more accurate
version of the Wyatt Earp Doc Holliday
story and Val Kilmer gives an iconic
performance in that one but Victor
Mature is really good in this and the
direction is beautiful it's a
black-and-white film but the use of
chiaroscuro is just gorgeous really a
good film worthy of the watch go check
out My Darling Clementine okay other
things that I like so there is an
article in The New York Times it's so
funny how folks on the left in the media
don't even understand what they are
writing about and so they think they are
writing the opposite of what they are
writing there's an article by Joanna
Klein called fighting the gender
stereotypes that warp biomedical
research and they say say you are
prescribed medication for depression
anxiety or even just to sleep would you
want to take it if you knew that the
drug can only been tested on male and
male animals rebecca schinsky
a neuroscientist at Northeastern
University in Boston thinks you might
not when she tells non-scientific
audiences that researchers from the most
part don't study female animals people
are blown away she added it seems like
such an obvious thing to a normal person
well you come up in the academic and
science world it's like oh no females
are so complicated so we just don't
study them in 2016 the National
Institutes of Health and its Canadian
counterpart mandated that all
preclinical research they fund must
include female subjects
now dr. Shan ski and other scientists
wondered if that requirement will do
enough to improve how research is
conducted in an essay published Thursday
in science dr. chance key questions
whether simply adding female organisms
to experiments or looking for sex
differences misses the point she warns
that this is a public health problem and
says scientists should design
experiments better suited to both
biological sexes she says if scientists
don't stop looking through a male lens
outdated gender stereotypes will
continue to foster dangerous assumptions
about the brain and behavior resulting
in clinical studies and eventual
treatments that don't work equally for
all people on the gender spectrum so
what is she saying she's saying we have
to treat the sexes differently so we can
treat the sexes the same is it sort of
where she is going now what's hilarious
about this and the reason I'm pointing
this out is that it is obvious to
scientists of all stripes then males and
females are different and yet we are
told by our media betters that males and
females are exactly the same except for
the fact that there are gender
stereotypes that have been placed on
males and females now I am all for more
scientific studies about what exactly is
the biological basis for differences
between males and females but a science
that fails to take into account those
differences and instead ignores those
differences on behalf of crap science
like suggesting that male and female are
cultural constructs and that gender
stereotypes are responsible for the vast
majority of differences between men and
women it is just a scientific nonsense
and when we study the animal kingdom we
all know this because there are no
social constructs in the animal kingdom
and yet science has very obviously treat
male and female animals differently as
well they should because they are
different the fact that the media are
now recognizing that it was sexist to
only perform experiments on male animals
I don't know how sexism can coexist with
the idea that there is no such thing as
biological sex if there's no such thing
as biological sex and gender is really
what we should be looking at
self-identification
as gender and how is sexism even an
issue it isn't really because what
exactly is the there's no biological
basis for the quote/unquote stereotype
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
well one of the nice things about AOC is
she's just a font of material so the the
the incredibly brilliant congresswoman
from at New York she did a bit of
bartending over the weekend to
demonstrate the plight of low-income
workers and she dropped this little gem
about what it must be like to be a
low-income worker working at a bar it is
so real the amount of exploitation and
harassment and labor violations that you
will endure for the state and the
structure of tipped work in in the
federal tipped minimum wage is three
dollars and 13 cents $2.13 an hour is
not a job it's a desert servitude and
then people cheer for this um me things
she does not understand the concept of
indentured servitude which was when a
person signed a fixed contract for a
long period of time and then had to work
off whatever debt they had by working
for the company you working at a job
that you signed up for at a wage that
you signed up for is not in fact
indentured servitude this idea that it's
exploitation to hire somebody to wage
they are willing to accept
he's absolute nonsense but again I
wouldn't expect AOC to know things I
mean that seems a little bit beyond her
can other things that I hate so it is
amazing how religious intolerance is
considered totally fine so long as it is
from radical Muslims there's a story
over the weekend Jews were allowed to
enter the Temple Mount for Jerusalem day
so one of the unbelievably ridiculous
things in Israel is that the Temple
Mount which is the holiest site in
Judaism long preexisting long
pre-existing even the existence of Islam
as a religion the holiest site in
Judaism has been the Temple Mount
there's not only the reason that is
called the Temple Mount is because it is
where the temple stood it is the amount
upon which the temple the Temple Mount
Jews are not generally allowed to pray
on the Temple Mount why because the
State of Israel out of its respect for
Islam decided to hand over the keys to
the Temple Mount to the Islamic walk
which is religiously discriminatory and
does not allow Jews to go up on the
Temple Mount and say Psalms and if you
say Psalms on the Temple Mount you could
be arrested by these
the troops that are supposed to guard
you why because everybody is so afraid
of ticking off the Muslims on the Temple
Mount who will then go and riot well why
are they so upset about this because
this is exactly what happens on the
Temple Mount on a fairly regular basis
when people talk about religious
discrimination in Israel let me make
this clear in Israel Muslims are allowed
to worship wherever they please Jews are
not allowed to worship wherever they
please out of some sort of deference
wrongheaded and stupid deference so
religiously intolerant bigots who
control the Temple Mount so over the
weekend here's what happened Jews were
allowed to enter the Temple Mount for
Jerusalem day they still weren't allowed
to say sometimes if you go up there and
you say Psalms they will actually arrest
you
riots broke out on the Temple Mount on
Sunday the commander of the Jerusalem
district Major General Dona deed ordered
the police to enter the Temple Mount and
take care of the rioters as the police
attempted to enter the place Arab
worshippers began throwing stones chairs
and other objects at the forces the
forces responded with riot dispersal
means Jews are generally forbidden to
enter the compound during the last days
of the month of Ramadan the police
allowed the entrance of Jews especially
for Jerusalem day and people rioted it's
amazing to me that Israel is considered
the religiously intolerant nation in the
region where Muslims are allowed to pray
openly worship basically worship
wherever they want
we're Muslims vote we're Muslim party
sit in the Knesset there are zero Jews
living under Palestinian Authority
dictates and if they Jews so much as
dares to step on the Temple Mount they
risk setting off a riot
but don't worry religious intolerance is
apparently the province of the Jews
according to the mainstream media it's
really ridiculous okay well we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of content go check
us out over then over there or we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
pride month is upon us when corporate
America politicians and even priests
cash in on America's obsession with
unusual sex we will analyze how the left
took the Queen of vices and turned it
into the most important virtue in the
country then the 2020 Democrats continue
to humiliate themselves check it out on
the Michael Noel's show